I want to go back and revisit Man of
Steel not because I want to recant
anything I said I still feel like the
movie does a great job of illustrating
the inherently fascist nature of most
superheroes ironically while trying to
tell a story about ostensibly the least
fascist superhero in fact like The Dark
Knight Rises Man of Steel seems to trip
over its own feet on the issue trying to
simultaneously explain why Batman and
Superman aren't mere psychotic power
fantasies but are instead deep morality
tales about the need for role models and
deities in human myth while presenting a
story that totally makes Superman and
Batman look like fascist frat boys who
are good guys in only the loosest sense
of the term The Dark Knight Rises tells
us Batman represents the same fascist
power structures that have allowed the
world to produce men like Bane and the
world is better off without Batman and
then asks us to root for Batman as he
restores the corrupt status quo and
enshrines the destructive influence of
the Batman's perpetual myth Man of Steel
tells us Superman is the good guy and
then demolishes metropolis cheap jabs
aside I do want to take a closer look at
Man of Steel because on some level I do
appreciate what it was trying to do the
story it was trying to tell the
implications it was trying to make the
themes it was trying to convey and the
mechanics it was trying to use there's
all these interesting things it was
trying to do but they just don't really
come together I'll touch on some of the
smaller elements as we go but the big
one I want to focus on is the structure
of the script or more specifically the
structure of the final story at it since
it's ultimately the root cause of most
of the other problems fundamentally the
structure of Man of Steel owes a lot to
the show Lost
while extensive use of flashbacks to
tell parallel stories is nothing new in
cinema its loss that really canonized
the technique in the minds of the modern
audience and the extent to which Man of
Steel uses the technique follows lost to
a tee right down to the aesthetics you
have the whole vague statement triggers
an audio lead that transitions into the
flashback thing
who's this guy my father believed that
if the world found out who I really was
they'd reject me fear
I'm tired of safe I just want to do
something useful with my life and the
giant whooshing sound transition thing
the Walker bounce we arranged here I'm
not just there's just one major problem
the stories in Man of Steel aren't
parallel or well they kind of are but
they're out of order or our missing
pieces the flashbacks don't fit in
thematically with the scenes that
surround them and they don't do a good
job of following Clark's adult arc this
problem is at the worst at the start of
the movie because once we leave the
prologue on Krypton the movie bogs down
into a slow-motion tableau where Clark
drifts around as a near mime interrupted
by irrelevant flashbacks the movie
basically kneecaps itself right here
this scene where Clark saves the dudes
on the oil rig is the wrong scene to
start his story with because it actively
undermines the tension the conflict and
themes that the movie hasn't even
finished setting up yet so let's touch
on that what are the themes of Man of
Steel think on that for a second
whatever you came up with you're
probably right because the movie has a
ton of themes that it's trying to juggle
at the same time and it turns into a bit
of a mess but I digress the three
primary themes of the movie are all
introduced in the prologue by Clark's
Kryptonian parents jor-el and Lara van
nelle this moment where they're putting
baby kal-el into the pod is functionally
the thesis statement of the film they
are one the power to choose between good
and evil abstracted is the power to
choose your own destiny to the rejection
of the unknown slash fear of rejection
and three cleansing the sins of Krypton
here's the problem they set these themes
up in the prologue but we still don't
know how Clark is going to interact with
them how does he feel about these issues
how have they shaped him does he even
care and the movie tells us it doesn't
really matter because more or less the
first thing Clark actively does in the
movie is
a bunch of people that's the foot we
start out on it's not a terrible foot to
start a Superman film on but it's a
terrible one to start this Superman film
out on because it cuts the tension
before we even get to it later when we
flashback to pot Kent telling teenage
Clark that he might have to make the
hard decisions where he chooses between
saving people and remaining anonymous
it's just wasted breath we already know
that Clark is running around doing good
than slinking away when no one's looking
I mean yes it's a Superman movie we
ultimately know what side he's going to
choose but that's not the point
the point is the tension of watching him
make that choice and the catharsis of
having the narrative confirmed because
it's faced at a Superman narrative as
bad as ritualistic as it gets this side
of high mass is gone because we already
have the answer before the movie has
finished asking the question and this is
unfortunate because this version of PAS
Kent has a worried cynical
overprotective father had the potential
to be really interesting they took the
risk of pissing off a lot of fans by
turning Pot Kent into a bit of a downer
in order to contrast his trepidation
against url's confidence that his son
would be a God among humanity it's a
change that has a lot of potential and
Kevin Costner sells it hard but the
movie does basically nothing with it the
scrambled nature of this chunk of the
movie is actually even worse than I've
eluded here's how he goes first there's
Clark on the fishing boat blah blah blah
he saves the river cruise and falls into
the ocean while he's floating in the
water we flashback to Clark as a kid
when his powers are going haywire
visually it's a neat scene but it's
actually almost useless we're gonna pin
it up over here and come back to it in a
bit but it's basically this scene about
making the world small that sounds super
deep and insightful but has zero impact
on the story we'll we'll come back to
this after that we're back to Clark in
the ocean he steals some clothes to hide
his abundant man flesh sees a school bus
and then were shot back into another
flashback so nothing of any real note
happened between the previous flashback
in this one that whole scene was just a
buffer but yeah it throws us into this
big flashback that's actually really
three separate scenes Clark saves the
school bus Clark and puck and to talk
about hard choices then pokken shows
Clark the potty arrived in alright we've
already looked at how the first
two-thirds of that is coming in too late
because we've already seen Clark's
decision but what about that last part
the scene ends with pokken telling Clark
that Clark owes it to himself to find
out whatever he can about where he came
from so he can figure out
he is and it leads into a scene where
Clark wrecks on douchebags truck yeah
that's pretty bad theming in fact it's
terrible theming the scene that follows
Clark working at the bar and getting
involved when his chode harasses the
waitress has absolutely nothing to do
with anything potkins said it does
however relate to a different flashback
later where Clark has a run-in with some
bullies but that's not coming for
another half-hour plot wise this scene
shows Clark learning that some mumbo
jumbo is going down up in the Arctic but
that information is tangental it's not
what causes Clark to leave and while he
shows some interest in the information
the vast majority of the scene is about
this interaction between him and the
douchebag we get the hint about the
Arctic but have forgotten about it by
the time the scene is over since we're
here and I have almost no reason to talk
about this scene again let's take a
moment to address just how dumb it is
let's set aside the fact that we know
Clark as Superman and can mash this guy
in to catch up even by mortal standards
Clark is a beef Mountain he's a foot
taller than this guy in lactates
testosterone douchebag trucker is the
stupidest person alive if he thinks he's
coming out ahead in this conflict also
Clark works at this bar given that Clark
is roughly the size of a grizzly bear
chances are good that kick drunk
[ __ ] out is right there in his job
description I mean come on it's a bar
drunk people get rowdy
I'm not saying Clark needs to turn this
dude into pudding he doesn't need to the
man is incapable of hurting him breaking
his grip were outrunning him he is as
threatening as a carton of eggs so
rather than just you know giving the guy
the boot Clark takes all the abuse the
guy dishes out quits his job on the spot
but gets petty revenge by wrecking his
truck also nitpick but this shot
demolished my suspension of disbelief I
don't know maybe trucks and logs are
just too familiar to make this work but
when I see this shot of the truck
impaled on logs all I can think of is
that there's no way the entire bargain
and here this happening what makes the
scene ultimately useless though is that
we don't end up in this same kind of
position again with Clark as Superman
there's no ultimate payoff speaking of
useless scenes we've still got this
wacky scene pinned up over here question
what purpose does this scene serve to
the movie wrong well okay maybe you
weren't wrong but yeah most likely what
whatever
the sole purpose of this sequence is to
establish Superman's power
super-hearing x-ray vision and heat
vision specifically that the onset of
these powers is disorienting so that
later in the film when he busts open
Zod's helmet we know why Zod immediately
starts tripping balls that's it
this scene otherwise does nothing for
plot or theme in the whole bit for ma
Kent about making the world small means
absolutely nothing it's hollow feel-good
bullcrap
anyway the broader point here is that
these flashbacks don't do their job we
don't have enough context for them to be
meaningful in fact I almost feel like
they shouldn't even be considered
flashbacks because they're way longer
than the adult Clark parts up to this
point where we switch gears and start
following Lois Lane we spent a grand
total of six minutes with adult Clark
and he set all of two lines we know
basically nothing about him but we have
to consider them flashbacks because well
I mean that's what they are the movie
establishes its chronology right off the
bat by leading with adult Clark and the
adult Clark section is you know where
the plot actually happens in the end
these arcs just don't line up by the
time we see the death of PAS Kent and
learn why Clark became a wandering
magical hobo it doesn't matter because
he's not a wandering magical hobo
anymore and hasn't been for a while he's
got a spaceship and a fancy costume and
a new dad and he can fly by the time we
get the morality lesson about using his
power against humans it doesn't matter
because he spends the rest of the movie
punching people who were just as
invincible as he is okay so how should
these flashbacks be used well that
depends on what your leading up to which
brings us to the heart of the problem
the film doesn't really build up to
anything the scene with Clark and the
bullies belongs back before the truck
scene and the you might need to let
people die scene needs to be put before
the oil rig rescue we're shown all this
stuff about Clark as a kid being
presented with the idea of difficult
choices in terms of how he should
interact with humanity but then his big
climactic conflict has very little to do
with his relationship to humanity or
vice-versa Zod shows up demands the
humanity to turn over some dude that no
one's ever heard of so humanity
naturally says screw it you can have
them so this whole theme of will
humanity accept or reject him is just
left on the table they keep talking
about it but it never comes to a head
it's never resolved the scenes where it
might be resolved or wrestled with Clark
revealing himself to humanity are
predetermined because by that point
they've been eclipsed by the world
threatening Zod problem
once Zod's on the scene Clark's personal
insecurities turn into peanuts Clark
doesn't need to struggle with being
accepted because he gets to walk up to
general mephone a-and go see that giant
ass ship up there they're gonna
everything up real bad you need me and
you can't even pretend that you don't
because you're clearly unprepared to
deal with it so thematically everything
that they promised us way back at the
beginning all this stuff about
challenging our notions of what it means
to be human our faiths our scientific
understanding
none of that plays a part of the climax
so let's go back and look at the core
themes and how each of them resolves
theme one good Clark or evil Clark this
is the one that we've already covered is
Clark going to help humanity or help
himself it's the most touched on theme
in the movie but it's also undercut by
the fact that we never actually see
Clark struggle with it the main body of
movie opens with him blatantly
unmistakeably using super powers to save
people and when Lois hunts his mom down
she finds a long trail of semi-secret
times Clark openly used his super powers
to help people when Clark has to decide
between turning himself over to Zod and
hiding it doesn't really matter because
everyone knows it's a dummy choice Clark
already knows Zod is space Hitler and
humanity has no reason to care about
Clark to humanity this whole thing is
Zod story and kal-el is just a footnote
most of them don't even know about
Superman until after the whole thing is
resolved so there's no stakes here
the only time Clark ever has anything to
lose by doing the right thing is when he
saves the school bus but that's
meaningless because by that point we
already know which side of the hole let
them live let them die question he came
down on because we saw the frickin oil
rig ultimately the script tries to rest
the stakes of this theme on the
shoulders of the second theme - fear of
the unknown / fear of rejection this
theme goes basically nowhere because
Superman never openly interacts with
Humanity in his own context only in the
context of Zod in fact he never actually
reveals himself officially to the
populace at large in the movie he
reveals himself to the military and to
Lois but not to the public his
interaction with the public is almost
entirely incidental or secondhand like
think about how this looks to those
people out on the street they don't know
who any of these people are it's just
three invincible monsters fighting each
other while the military shoots
Superman means nothing to them he's not
friend he's not foe he's just a stranger
they try to resolve this theme by having
the US military act as a stand-in for
humanity Clark presents himself to the
military he bros it up with soldiers and
its soldiers who were Dain him as
acceptable this man is not our enemy
I get where they're going with that but
I'm sorry no the US military is not an
effective proxy for Humanity
so acceptance is supposed to be the
thing at stake but Superman never risks
rejection on his own terms
his reveal is a reaction to Zod two
demands he as Superman has no
relationship with humanity but were
repeatedly told that his relationship
with humanity is what's at stake theme
three cleansing the sins of Krypton the
only thing Matt ik element to pay off in
the climax is cleansing the sins of
Krypton but it's a theme that gets so
little traction elsewhere that when it
does come up it feels out of place
honestly I feel like these are the best
parts of the movie even if they are
abrupt the opening moments of the movie
on Krypton actually do a very very good
job at communicating a lot of depth in a
really short span of time I find it easy
to grok why Krypton is backed into a
corner by its own hubris and stubborn
pride I get why Zod would attempt a coup
and empathize with his motives even if I
agree with jor-el that a coup is a
wasted effort that misses the point
polishing the brass on the Titanic if
you will I like the tragic irony in
Zod's trial this elaborate punitive
pageant showing off deeply misplaced
priorities in the face of utter
destruction
the prologue does a really good job
showing the audience that Krypton is
more advanced but still vulnerable
that's some really really good material
to parallel later on but as with the
other themes a lot of this just gets
left on the table still some good
moments come out of it like when jor-el
implies that he's kind of a racist and
doesn't care about humans even if he
knows intellectually that he should he
knows that no matter how hard he tries
he still the product of a corrupt doomed
world and nothing short of a full reset
will fix that the whole reason why he
withheld information from kal is because
he didn't want his son to grow up with
the same ideological and cultural biases
that ultimately doomed Krypton it's a
potentially powerful concept where Clark
should come to the realization that
neither his earth parents nor his
Kryptonian parents were perfect
to pull this back to the problems with
the structure Cal ultimately rejecting
the rebirth of Krypton should parallel
alongside Clark rejecting potkins
timidity but that's a moment that we
never get like I said these scenes are
kind of great on their own but they're
really really isolated and dense and
function mostly as giant info dumps I
mean that's all they really are giant
info dumps jor-el even prepared slides
for his Zod on the other hand went with
the immersive hallucinogenic
phantasmagoria option unfortunately the
resolution of this theme is a bit
unfortunate so there's this colony scout
ship right it's nothing super fancy but
it's got a couple baby trees inside and
if you turn the thing on you're going to
have a whole town of super babies
everywhere so this ship creates a
physical representation of Clark's
connection to Krypton and the power to
bring Krypton back and Clark cuts it in
half and crashes it into the ground
including the baby trees
now I'm not criticizing that decision
it's dark it's potent but I think Clark
should treat it with a bit more gravitas
then oh I don't know this Wow Lois way
to be a buzzkill also no no one says
that if they say that then they're
kissing the wrong people or they are the
wrong people and you shouldn't be
kissing them anyway this theme sees its
ultimate resolution during the second
ending of the movie when Clark kills Zod
this also represents the biggest dropped
ball in the film the movie never tells
us why we should care about this moment
or why this moment was so important
because it hinges on two things that
were never demonstrated that Superman
doesn't kill and that he laments the
death of those he failed to save
something to keep in mind as well is
that this is a movie that has literally
stopped the plot several times for
lectures on the ethics of conflicting
choice in all of jor-el and pockets
lectures not once did the sanctity of
life ever come up there's a lot of talk
about hope potential choice changing the
world good and evil personal growth
focus and purpose but nothing about not
killing if anything were given the exact
opposite implication because more than
once it's apparent that Clark is trying
really really hard to kill Zod this is
possibly the single biggest misstep of
the movie and it's a mistake by omission
we are never shown the moment where
morally spiritually Superman is born
we're shown his physical ascent when he
gets the suit and learns to fly and
outwardly become Superman as bad as it
is were shown his public ascent where he
reveals himself but were never shown
that critical moment where Clark goes
sorry dad I disagree I can't stand by
and watch people suffer while I have the
power to help them does the Superman
movie need to show that moment no but
this one did every theme almost every
flashback points towards that moment
where Clark decides to be Superman where
he's given a legitimate choice to walk
away or intervene and yet that decision
is never put up on screen and you know
what I think that's that there's more
that I could get into like the
monumental stupidity of the tornado
scene the reductive boring axe
sequences the love affair with military
authority how bad the Daily Planet is at
their own job and the ham-handed Christ
metaphor is that they still manage to
screw up despite it being one of the
easiest stories to tell but you know
what I'm going to call it there for now
take care of you beautiful sexy people